*Musique*
♫ [Générique] A travers les époques, les dangers, une grande aventure les appelle, c'est, c'est l'épopée temporelle. ♫
Narrateur: Ah le Far-West, les révolvers, les cow-boys, Woody ! Ahahah...
...Nos amis Iris, Eliot et les deux Thomas sont accueillis...
...par un énorme rayon laser...
...qui traverse le ciel. Ils doivent réparer le temps...
...mais que va-t-il leur arriver ?...
...J'en sais rien !...
...Je vous rappelle qu'on ne me file plus les scénarios en avance !...
...C'est décidé je fais grève!
*bruit médiéval, chevaux*
Thomas : Qu'est-ce qui a changé à cette époque ?
Iris : Le rayon laser qui vient de traverser le ciel et d'exploser cette maison !...
...Tu trouves ça normal ?
Eliot : Cherchons des informations dans ce *saloon*.
Thomas du futur: Bonjour messieurs!
Les cow-boys du saloon : Cachez-vous !
Thomas :  Waa cool des cow-boys comme dans West-world !
Cow-boy: Ne nous tuez pas!  Par pitié !
Iris : Calmez-vous ! Calmez-vous, on vous veut aucun mal.
Cow-boy: Dites à Flamme Bleue qu'on allait partir. OK ?
Thomas : Avec plaisir ! On va faire ça.
Thomas du futur : C'est qui Flamme Bleue ?
Thomas : Aucune idée
Iris : Dites messieurs ...
Cow-boy: Ne nous tuez pas, pour l'amour de Dieu. Regardez on a seulement des vulgaires pistolets.
Iris : Mais tout va bien nous sommes des voyageurs.   Qu'est-ce qui ce passe ici ?
Cow-boy: Les indiens, ils nous attaquent, c'est un massacre !
Iris : Vous voulez dire que c'est vous qui les massacrez ?
Iris : Vous voulez dire que c'est vous qui les massacrer ?
Les cow-boys : Mais non, ils nous tuent par centaines.
Les cow-boys : Mais non, ils nous tuent par centaines
[Bruit de foule]
Eliot : J'ai l'impression qu'on a trouvé notre bouleversement temporel.
Eliott : J'ai l'impression qu'on a trouvé notre bouleversement temporel
Le cow-boy : C'est Flamme-bleue ! Il a une arme maudite, une lumière bleue qui transforme tout en poussières.
Eliot: Hmm, ça doit être un canon à anti-matière ...
Eliott: Hmm, ça doit être un canon à anti-matière ...
Iris: que notre ennemi a donné aux autochtones, mais oui!
Iris: Que notre ennemi a donné aux autochtones, mais oui!
Le cow-boy : Vous, vous connaissez cette arme ? Oh, aidez-nous s'il vous plait !
Autre cow-boys: Ouais, nous les cow-boys on est oppressé
Iris : Mouais vous êtes sûrs que c'est pas vous qui avez commencé ?
Cow-boy : Quoi ? Embêter les Indiens ?
Euuh on a rien fait on est super sympa avec eux. Euh pas vrai les gars ?
Le saloon: Ouais ! Ouais on a rien fait !
Eliot : Mes capteurs détectent *un gros pipeau.*
Thomas : Quoi ? Ils seraient en train de .. mentir ?
Cow-boy : On dit la vérité, on est les victimes dans cette histoire, vous vous rendez compte c'est à cause de notre couleur de peau qu'ils nous aiment pas...
...ils sont intolérants ces Indiens !
Iris : Ouais, j'arrive pas a compatir
Thomas du futur : Moi non plus, et pourtant j'ai pleuré en découpant mon premier avocat
Iris : Non c'est en découpant des oignons qu'on pleure
Thomas du futur : Je ne connais pas cette profession
Cow-boy : Mais non ! Ils nous tuent par centaines
Thomas : On dirait que les bolosseurs se font bolosser
Autre cow-boys : Quoi ?? Ça te fait plaisir qu'on s'fasse martyriser ?
Cow-boy énervé: Ouais, tu cherches la bagarre, gringualais ?!
Thomas du futur : Mollo les crasseux ! Un mot d'plus a mon faible ami Thomas du passé...
...Et j'en fouette un avec la colonne vertébrale de l'autre.
Cow-boy énervé: Ok ok ok ok ...
...Mais même...
Thomas du futur: Chut !
Thomas : Ouh ouh, j'aurais pas aimé.
Cow-boy: Mais monsieur...
Thomas du futur: J'veux pas savoir !
Iris : Tu les as séchés, hein?
Eliot : Les guerres de territoire entre les peuples natifs et les colons sont censées...
...perdurer encore. Et même si on peut trouver ça injuste, il faut rétablir l'histoire.
Iris : Bon allons à la rencontre du peuple natif.
*Musique de transition indienne*
Eliot : Bien, le village se trouve à quelques *centaines de mètres*.
Eliot : Quelqu'un approche.
[bruit chevaux qui courent avec des cries Indien]
Thomas : C'est qui lui ?
Thomas du futur : On dirait le chef de la tribu .
Flamme-Bleue: Je suis Flamme-Bleue, chef et...
...protecteur de cette région. Étrangers,...
...Venez-vous en paix ?
Thomas : Grave !...
...Paix et prospérité !
Chef indien : Quel est ce signe de main ?
...Vous aussi vous voulez opprimer mon peuple ?
Iris : Pas du tout ! On veut juste comprendre ce qu'il se passe ici.
...Avez-vous vécu des évènements,...
...disons, inhabituels dans votre région ?
Flamme-Bleue : Il y a eu une crue et la lune était particulièrement basse, hier...
...Ah oui, aussi il y a un être de métal qui est apparu du Ciel et qui m'a donné une arme capable de détruire les montagnes.
Iris : Voilà, ça c'est inhabituel !...
...Les méchants robots qu'on a vu chez Leonard de Vinci est venu ici.
Chef indien : Grâce à cette arme nous avons pu repousser les envahisseurs...
...D'ailleurs, toi, bonhomme de métal, tu me rappelles l'esprit des cieux.
Eliot : Je ne suis pas tout a fait comme elle..
Iris : Eh bien figurez-vous que nous venons du même endroit que cet être des cieux. ...
*Reprise de respiration*
...Alors pouvons nous voir l'arme par curiosité ?
Flamme-Bleue : *Ricanne* Admirez la force du ciel !...
*Crie de puissance*
* Bruit d'un laser puissant*
Eliot : Hum... C'est bien un canon longue portée "MZ-675 à anti-matière"
Flamme-Bleue : Je préfère l'appeler : FLAMME-BLEUE
Iris : C'est très impressionant !...
...*en chuchotant*  : Mais QU'EST-CE QU'ON FAIT ?!
Eliot : C'est l'arme la plus puissante qui existe à notre époque «l’an deux-mille-quatrev...»
Thomas : *éternue dans ses mains*
Thomas : AH désolé :/ C'est la poussière du désert.
Thomas du futur: Argh, Thomas du passé ; t'en as plein les doigts....
Iris : On peut pas leur prendre l'arme...
... Ça va condamner cette population à affronter les cow-boys...
...et on sait comment ça se termine.
Thomas : Ah on peut pas faire ça !
Thomas du futur : J'suis d'accord avec mon moi du passé.
Eliot : Oui, mais notre priorité est d'empêcher les modifications du temps...
...Si le temps subit trop de changements notre réalité s'effondrera. ...
... Le lapin de viendra pas nous chercher. ...
... Nous serons coincés ici, et on laissera le méchant réussir son plan machiavélique...
... qu'on a même pas vraiment compris.
Thomas : Ah on peut pas faire ça !
Thomas du futur : J'suis d'accord avec mon moi du passé.
Iris : Merci les gars pour vos avis tranchés...
...Eliot, ça se voit que t'es pas humain, toi...
...ça te fait rien de laisser un peuple se faire opprimer ?
Eliot : Pas humain? Toi, tu as bien laissé couler le *Titanic*.
Enfant : À l'aide ! Sauvez-moi !
Flamme-Bleue: Malheur !
Enfant : Je me noie !
Flamme-Bleue : Il y a petite brindille dans le fleuve
Thomas: Une brindille ? Ils sont vraiment a fond sur la nature
Flamme-Bleue : Non! Petite brindille est mon fils! C'est son nom!
Eliot: Dans le fleuve en bas du précipice, un enfant se noie...
Flamme-Bleue: Il faut le sauver!
Iris: On est trop loin!
Eliot : Ses chances de survies sont de 0,000...
Thomas du futur: J'y vais *crie de saut*
Iris: Thomas, fais attention !
Thomas: Woh ! Il a sauté !
... Je suis vraiment courageux.
Iris: Il adore prendre des risques, il accourt vers le danger...
... comme un enfant vers un camion de glace.
Petite brindille : À l'aide !
Flamme-Bleue : Tiens bon petite brindille!
Thomas du futur: Ne t'inquiète pas , j'arrive petit !
Flamme-bleue: Quelle nage magnifique!
Eliot: Il fait du *dos crawlé*.
Iris: Vas-y Thomas !
Flamme-Bleue : Allez !
Thomas du futur : Je le tiens !
Iris : Oui c'est bon, il tient l'enfant.
Petite-brindille: Derrière vous, monsieur !
Eliot : Attention un ours dans l'eau !
Thomas du futur: Oh non... Va-t'en ours...
Iris: Un ours?!
...Je ne suis pas ton ennemi.
Iris: Courage Thomas !
...Attention!
*grognement, attaque*
Iris: Oh, ils se battent!
*grognements*
*étonnement général*
Flamme-Bleue : Vous faites ça bien !
Iris: Ouais ! L'ours s'en va !
Thomas du futur : *crie* Ah! Mon bras !
Eliot: Oh non, l'ours lui a arraché : *un bras*.
Thomas: Oh non! Notre bras!
Flamme-Bleue : Aïe ! Ça doit faire mal !
Eliot : Il monte la paroi rocheuse avec un seul bras et l'enfant sur les épaules.
Iris : Il a réussi !
Thomas : YES !
Flamme-Bleue : Petite brindille, tu es vivant mon fils.
Iris: Ouais! Bravo Thomas !
Thomas :  *se ventant* Rooh, tu sais j'ai supporté comme j'ai pu. C'est pas grand chose.
Iris: Mais c'est pas a toi que je parlais Thomas du passé.
Thomas du futur: Le petit garçon est en sécurité maintenant...
... *étonné* Ou est mon bras ?
Eliot : cette blessure est étrange...
... aucune trace de sang ni de chair.
Iris : Ça, ce n'est pas humain
Thomas du futur : Peut-être que je cicatrice vite ?
Eliot : Il semble que ce soit une matière synthétique hybride et polymorphique.
Thomas : Tu es en mousse mec !
Iris : Il est en mousse ?
Thomas du futur : Je.. je ne comprends pas
Iris : Tout... tout est en mousse ?
Flamme-Bleue : *en chantant* ♫
Flamme bleue a failli perdre petite brindille ♫
Thomas : Heu, il est vraiment en train de chanter ?
Flamme-Bleue : *en chantant* ♫ l'homme fort a jailli plongeant seul dans les rapides... ♫
♫ ...le courant était fort mais l'enfant il put porter... ♫
♫ ...l'ours brin aux abords pris un bras pour son goûter... ♫
... ♫ ainsi prenez : «L'ARME SACRÉE!» ♫
Flamme-Bleue : ♫ L'arme sacrée...♫
Iris : Non ! non ! On n'en veut pas! gardez-la!
Iris: Non, je vous assure! On ne pas récupérer l'arme.
Iris : Gardez-la ! Ça peux vous servir...
Flamme-Bleue : ♫ prenez cette flamme impur qui vont causer des soucis...♫
♫ .. .elles sont contre nature, elles n'ont rien a faire ici.... ♫
♫ ... pour défendre ces terres, je reprends mon nom d'avant... ♫
♫ ... que m'ont donné mes frères qui scalpent l'homme blanc. ♫
Thomas: Ça sonnait mieux «Flamme-Bleue».
Chef tribu : Vous n'êtes pas humain, peuple du ciel...
...et je comprends que cette arme ne devrait pas être ici, c'est contre nature. ...
...Merci d'avoir sauvé petite brindille...
...Nous lutterons comme avant avec nos arcs et nos flèches...
...pour maintenir le cours des choses et cette arme parasite, je m'en débarrasse.
Thomas : Vous êtes tellement classe
Iris : Bon bah comme vous voudrez...
... mais juste comme ça, si vous avez l'occasion, passez aux armes a feu...
Chef tribu : Maintenant, rentrons petite brindille
Petite brindille : Papa je m'appelle Enzo, arrête avec ça tu me fous le honte
*bruit d'apparition*
Le lapin : Je suis de retour !
Thomas : Cool ! On a du réussir notre mission si le petit lapin est là. ...
... Wooh ! Tout est bien qui fini bien !
Iris : Ouais... enfin parle pour nous...
... Petit lapin tu peux nous ramener au laboratoire ?
... j’aimerais discuter avec mon père a propos de Thomas...
Le lapin : Hein? Mais qu'est ce qu'il a Thomas ?
... Carotte de bique ! Il est ou son bras ?!
... bon, je vois, mettez vous autour de moi. ...
... Pour le voyage, j'ai des bonbons et diverses boissons.
Thomas : Oh cool ! Des mentos. ...
... Est-ce que je peux charger mon téléphone ?
Le lapin : C'est un iPhone ?
Thomas : Ouais.
Le lapin : 417 ou 418 ? Parce que ce n'est pas le même embout.
Thomas: un 6s.
Le lapin : je n'vais pas avoir. ...
... RE-TEMPORALISATION !
*bruit voyage espace avec legers cries des passagers*
Le lapin : Et voilà ! On est arrivé, mettez moi 5 étoiles et je ferais pareil !
Iris : Papa ?
Docteur Simon : Ah ! Vous êtes de retour...
...vous avez arrêté la personne qui modifie le ...
...ho Iris je n'aime pas ton regard...
Iris: C'est quoi ça ?
Thomas : Regardez mon moi du futur ! Il a plus de bras et on dirait qu'il est fait de mousse ou un truc de genre.
Docteur Simon : En simulose pour être précis...
Iris : Quoi ?
Thomas du futur : Je suis en quoi ?
Iris : Mais, qu'est ce que tu nous cache papa ?
Docteur Simon: Bon, ok... je vais tout vous dire... J'ai failli vous en parler mais j'ai eu peur que vous le preniez mal...
...Thomas du futur ne vient pas du futur.
Iris : Hein ?
Thomas : Hein ?
Thomas du futur : Quoi ?!
Docteur Simon : *rire nerveux* il n'est pas d'ici non plus... en faites, c'est un peu compliqué...
... Vous voyez l'ordinateur là ?
... j'ai recréé virtuellement le monde que nous connaissons et ses habitants...
Tout le monde : Hein ? Quoi ?
Iris : Une simulation de notre monde ?
Thomas du futur : Je viens d'un monde virtuel ?
Docteur Simon : oui et figurez-vous que qu'on peut sortir quelqu'un de la simulation...
...il suffit de taper son nom sur ce clavier...
Thomas : Ah ! C'est moi qui l'ai fait sortir en tapant mon nom
Docteur Simon : Exactement !
Thomas : du coup c'est pas un Thomas du futur donc...
...je suis plus Thomas du passé donc...
...maintenant on m'appelle Thomas tout court...
...et donc lui c'est Thomas en mousse
*rires* ...
Ça va Thomas en mousse ?
Thomas du futur : Je n'existe pas...
Thomas: Et ouais Thomas en mousse!
Eliot: Tu es cruel Thomas tout court...
Docteur Simon: Désolé Thomas en mousse...
...tu sors tout droit de cette imprimante 3D à simulose...
...je vais vous montrer...
Prenons un exemple: si je tape une colombe...
*bruits d'imprimante*
Docteur Simon : Ah merde, il n'y a plus de rouge... Bougez pas! Je change la cartouche. ...
... Argh, c'est con de changer toutes les cartouches de couleurs alors qu'il me reste du jaune et du bleu. ...
... Je te jure, alors vraiment...
...Voilà! Tout ça pour qu'on dépense plus, j'te jure!
*bip de validation*
Docteur Simon : Et voilà !
Thomas : Oh ! Le petit oiseau blanc. ...
Aïe !!! Il me mord !
Iris : Ah mais c'est quoi ça ?
Thomas : Je sens ses dents! Lâche moi! Piaf à la con...
Docteur Simon : Bouge pas ! J'ai mon Tazer.
*bruit déclenchement taser*
Docteur Simon: On a eu chaud...
...elle allait planter son dard et son venin est fatal...
Iris : Mais... c'est quoi ce bordel ? on a jamais vu une colombe avec des dents et un dard venimeux.
Docteur Simon : Oui, Non non non... mais ça, je sais ! C'est à cause de la simulation...
...à la base, c'était un monde très paisible et suite a un problème... beh... c'est devenu... beh ce que c'est devenu.
Thomas du futur : Le royaume du feu, de la violence, de la mort et du désespoir!
Iris : Papa ! On est partis dans le temps avec un Frankenstein qui vient d'un monde chaotique que tu as créé !
... Non, mais tu te rends compte du danger dans lequel tu nous as mis ?!
Docteur Simon : Tu vois Iris, quand je vois comment tu as réagis, je me dis que j'ai bien fait de vous le cacher.
Iris : Mais non ! Avec ta logique de merde hein.
Docteur Simon: Bon allez, on oublie tout ça...
Docteur Simon : Je rebranche Thomas virtuel à son monde.
Thomas du futur : Quoi ? Je dois retourner là-dedans ?
Docteur Simon : Ne t'inquiète pas, tout va bien se passer, assieds-toi
Thomas: Oh, il va nous manquer Thomas en mousse
Docteur Simon : Voilà... J'ai juste à mettre ce petit câble dans ton oreille...
*Bruit bouton appuyé*
Thomas du futur : Ah ! Ah non ! Une chaise m'attaque, ah non ! Je souffre... Je dois construire des explosifs...
Ah non, de la lave !
... une vague de lave ! Je souffre !
*bruit bouton appuyé*
Docteur Simon : Oups, j'avais oublié de couper le son.
*bip bip alarme*
Docteur Simon: Merde, merde, merde ! Quelqu'un essaie encore de modifier le temps !
... qui ça peut bien être ?
Thomas : On l'a vu ! C'est un robot ! On l'a croisé chez Leonardo DiCaprio !
Docteur Simon : Un robot ?
Thomas : Thomas en mousse l'a fait fuir !
Docteur Simon : Quel robot ?
Iris : Ça, on va le savoir et le mettre hors état de nuire !
... Petit lapin, emmène nous aux coordonnées !
Le lapin : C'est parti pour la ville de Rome ! En -100 avant Jésus-Christ
Eliot : Parfait ! Allons-y !
Docteur Simon : Je compte sur vous !
Iris : Allez en route, Thomas du passé !
*bruit portail de téléportation*
Thomas : Rooh non, ne m'appelle pas comme ça!
*cries*
*sons de voyage dans le temps*
Narrateur : Oh oh ! Quelle aventure ! Thomas du futur provient en réalité d'un monde virtuel !
... Je n'en reviens pas. Et maintenant, nos héros vont dans la romantique pour arrêter ce satané robot fouteur de troubles. ...
... Pardon ? Ma grève ? *ricane* J'étais tellement à fond dans l'histoire que j'ai oublié ma grève. *rire*
Cyprien : Merci d'avoir écouté cet épisode et à la semaine prochaine pour la suite de L'Épopée temporelle.